[Musique]
le geste est sûr d'une précision
remarquable des multitudes de petites
gouttelettes fixé sur une toile en une
fraction de seconde un art exceptionnel
dont andré arts à vaumas tony est l'un
des seuls au monde à maîtriser
parfaitement
sur des murs de 15 à 30 mètres de haut
le graveur italien est capable de
reproduire avec une fidélité
déconcertante les tableaux des plus
grands maîtres comme ici en italie en
[Musique]
moi j'ai fait la traduction de l'ancien
maître avec la bombe parce que je
n'utilise pas la même les mains
techniques et tous les x je fais encore
l'action avec les territoires
je prends des des tableaux qui sont dans
les musées de la ville
je le fais sortir et aussi fait partie
du louvre date faire des courses avec
l'école avec les élèves avec des
l'historique de l' art qu'ils
travaillent avec moi et voilà qu'est ce
que c'est mon travail faire
contemporaine mais je portemanteau
tradition très ancienne
fils et petit fils d'artistes
autodidactes du graf andre arts à vaumas
tony a commencé à l'âge de 14 ans avant
de se former au musée des beaux-arts
la jeune fille est la perle de vermeer
la jeune orpheline au cimetière de
delacroix
il n'hésite pas à réaliser des
classiques sur des petits formats plus
c'est petit plus c'est difficile parce
que la bande s'est pas on pense d un
poil il ya en taille qui peut être des
11 cm au plus petit j'utilise la
pression j'utilise des manières
différentes mais c'est vraiment plus
difficile faire des toiles et qui est
des grains mieux la présence de
l'artiste en touraine est tout sauf un
hasard
andres à vaumas tony est venu en
résidence pour réaliser des commandes à
l'appel d'une association et de cet
homme un des grands spécialistes du
street art en france son arrêt
exceptionnel pour moi c'est un grand
talent il sort l'art des musées pour le
mettre dans la rue ça c'est quelque
chose d'assez exceptionnel pour moi qui
suis je prône et je défends c'est là un
art pour tous
à l'heure du comique 19 et des musées
fermés le street art n'a sans doute
jamais été aussi précieux pour
s'échapper s'évader andrea ravaux ma
tony l'a bien compris son souhait
abreuvés de poésie le monde avec des
classiques à ciel ouvert